Speaker 1: And speaking of things that
also make absolutely no sense whatsoever.
New reports have revealed that ICE officials
were instructed by the Trump administration
to wipe their cell phones before he left
office. So prior to January 20th of 2021,
we have ICE officials. It has now been confirmed,
of course. That deleted all of the data
off of their phones, just like we saw with.
Speaker 2: Members of the Department of Justice.
Members of the Department of Homeland Security.
Speaker 1: And, of course, most famously,
the United States Secret Service. Everybody just
wiped all their phones, deleted everything off
it. Text messages, emails, notes, games,
whatever. It was totally erased. It all.
And even if just like the Secret
Service claimed. Right. Oh,
this was just routine. We just. This is a
thing we do. Cool. Totally understand that.
You're still required by law to preserve
the data. And that's the big part that I
think a lot of people don't quite understand
about this. It is not routine for the DOJ,
for the Homeland Security, for the Secret Service
to just wipe everything off the phone and turn it
back in and say, all right, thank you. Bye. I'll
see you next time. No, the phones are taken.
Inventory is done. They are copied.
Speaker 2: And then they are wiped.
Speaker 1: And this, of course, only applies to
agency issued phones, which most of these people
do have agency issued phones, and they have it for
that specific reason so that the data is saved,
so that there are records of the things that
they do, the communications that they have,
so that they can make sure these individuals
are not sending it to people who shouldn't
be receiving it. And in case there's
any malfeasance, we can point it out.
Speaker 2: Due to the records on their devices.
Speaker 1: And now we know that ICE,
Immigrations and Customs Enforcement wiped
their phones just like so many other government.
Speaker 2: Agencies under Donald Trump.
Speaker 1: I don't know how much more of this
we can go through. How many more cell
phones were wiped before Trump left?
How many other agencies, how many other officials
were given these orders to scrub it all,
to get rid of any evidence, get rid of any
trace of anything, make sure nobody knows
who we were talking to. And when we were talking
to them and what we were talking to them about.
That should terrify you. And every single person
involved needs to be investigated because like I
said, it's illegal. To delete these records. They
are required by law to back them up. And I'm not
saying go find the IT department and arrest those
guys for wiping their devices. They probably
didn't know that they hadn't been backed up.
Whoever made the call, whoever made the decision
for all of these devices to be wiped at whatever
agency it is we're talking about that day.
Those are the people that need.
Speaker 2: To be held accountable.
Speaker 1: And maybe there's a couple honest
folks in there. Maybe some of them backed up
their own data. Maybe they understood
that I was just following orders is not
necessarily a good excuse for breaking the law.
Speaker 2: So maybe there are records somewhere.
Speaker 1: Right? Even in the case of the Secret
Service, in all their missing cell phone data,
once the investigation was lost, they came
back and magically said, oh, wait, wait,
we just found data on ten devices. Look at that.
Wow. Oh, suddenly it's crazy. We may be looking
at a situation like that, but only if we put
the pressure on these organizations. And that
pressure has to either come from Congress or it
has to come from the Biden administration via the.
Speaker 2: Department of Justice.
That's what has to happen.
Remains to be seen, though,
right? I guess we have to wait.